croyez le ou non deadpool 2 est un film
familial est ce que tu pourrais sortir
pas vraiment que je m'en aille c'est
notre anniversaire avec ma copine
ce gamin est en difficulté tu t'appelles
russell c'est ça ailleurs fils ilan en
vrai battre à coucher dehors j'ai essayé
de lui dire il a besoin de toi
voici le plan
sauvé gamin rentrer à la maison faire le
bébé
c'est pas trop comme ça que ça marche
mais on a essayé efforts maximums
présente-toi dominion du quoi ton truc à
toi que j'ai beaucoup de chance si la
chance est pas un super pouvoir
messi mais non pour moi les choses qui
misent toujours bien
mais c'est pas super pouvoirs expliqué
et s'ils sont m
ça
on coupe la poire en deux on n'a qu'à
dire non da rocha disais qu'est ce que
j'ai comme chose
weeds ton coeur les justes si tu
t'entraînes toi aussi tu peux être x man
x men c'est pas ma came mais alors pas
du tout parce que tout d'abord on m'a
déjà des puces clé je le protégerai
contre câbles mais tout seul je peux pas
je suis à x manière ta gueule tu as tout
est sinon que je crains justin bieber a
tu as vu tu ta prise pour justin bieber
et paris
dès qu'un bouffon déguisé en jouer
tellement d'arc
tu es sûr que tu viens pas le nez vers
dc comics